hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book two of his work on anger
starting in chapter 28 Seneca is going
to provide us with some you could call
them Reflections or admonitions to use
one of the terms that he himself brings
up about how we ought to look at our own
behavior and the behavior of others and
how we should exercise some
self-awareness not his term but it's a
great blanket term and he thinks that by
doing this we will help to keep
ourselves from being as angry or perhaps
even getting angry at all at things and
actions that we see other people doing
or when we ourselves are being
criticized so he begins this by telling
us that if we want to be fair I Quee
Equitable judges then we need to realize
something and that something is a very
very general statement he says let's
convince ourselves that none of us is
without fault Cena culpa kulpa is
something that you've done wrong or are
going to do wrong in some cases because
intentions count as well and so when
we're admitting to our own faults we're
you know in a better situation
he tells us that the greatest
indignation uses that term indignacio
arises has its origin from two
statements one is I'm without sin or
literally I don't sin I didn't sin you
know
in this and I did nothing I didn't do
anything right I did nothing wrong so
those
commitments those assumptions those
postures on our part lead us into
certain problems and one of these is
resenting getting angry at other people
who criticize or admonish us admonizio
right they're telling us hey don't go
down that line or you're going to wind
up in trouble we don't like to hear that
right we don't like people telling us
that we're doing the wrong thing let
alone
restraining us uh kitsio right we don't
like that either and why do we resent
that well because we we think we didn't
do anything wrong and so who is this
person to criticize or to restrict me in
any way
Seneca also talks about us and this is
where the real meat comes in getting
angry with other people for doing the
same things that committing the same
misdeeds or sins
that we do the same wrongs and so we
might be especially sensitive to this we
might be projecting we might be just you
know rather egotistical and think that
we get to do things and nobody else gets
to do them and so you know he thinks
that this is a significant problem
something that we really need to pay
attention to and he says who's that
person there who claims that they're
innocent before all laws and that he
makes a really important contrast even
though that might be so what a pinched
innocence what a what a compressed
innocence is uh that which which merely
fulfills the law right uh to be legally
good how much more broadly he says the
norm of appropriate actions extends
beyond the rule of law and both of these
terms require a little bit of
explanation so rule of law here is the
way that it's translated in this
particular Edition regula
literally the rules of the law so
fulfilling the law as it's written out
or as it's been interpreted that's sort
of a baseline right that does not mean
that you're just yet because you could
certainly do things that are not
strictly speaking illegal but are not
fulfilling your appropriate actions or
we another way of translating This this
term ophikia is duties we don't fulfill
the wide range of what it is that we we
should do what we owe to other people
so merely saying well I didn't violate
any law if that's even a true statement
it's not enough so Seneca is going to
talk about some positive
characteristics that any decent person
should show and be motivated by devotion
pietas right and so this is not just to
the gods but to other people who we
should respect for example parents or
our teachers or people like that uh
Humanity humanitas being Humane to other
people being decent compassionate
towards them uh generosity liberalitas
so being willing to you know sometimes
give a little bit here and there not to
demand strict Justice on your part
Justice itself eustitia very important
and then finally a very interesting one
good faith fetus this is going to come
up more than once
Phoenix could also be understood as
loyalty it could also be understood as
being trustworthy by other people so all
of these are characteristics that we
should be ourselves cultivating and
insofar as we don't cultivate them and
don't act on them we're actually
screwing up and you know so if we're
going to criticize other people for
their lapses we should probably look at
our own lapses first and he says by the
way you don't get off the hook if you
didn't actually do the thing that the
person that you're criticizing and angry
at did themselves because you know he
talks about uh a whole bunch of it's
almost like a chain he says some things
we've done Alia fecky moose right so
some things and then another Aliyah
meaning another set of things we have
planned or thought over kogi tavimus
right so maybe we didn't actually you
know steal the the money that was left
out
um but we thought about it
and the fact that we thought about it
means that we're not a hundred percent
when it comes to these positive
qualities
or are we hoped for
optavimus other things right other
things that we shouldn't be hoping for
right we don't actually plan it out but
we're like oh wouldn't that be nice you
know we see somebody who's attractive
but we're in a committed relationship
and we we don't do anything with them we
don't even talk to them we don't plan
out anything with them but we think to
ourselves oh wouldn't it be nice if I
was unattached and I could sleep with
that person well that's you know
that's not the uh same thing as you've
committed adultery in your heart of the
gospels but it's pretty close isn't it
and then he talks about supporting
favimus right there are some things that
we didn't ourselves do but we
we didn't criticize other people who we
should have for doing it in fact we
actually maybe said there you go good
job right and so he says
in some cases we're only innocent
because we didn't get our way so with
this thought in mind
let's treat miscreants more fairly and
pay heed to those who rebuke us so two
different sets here people who are
actually doing something wrong and we're
getting angry with them but we don't
realize that we do or plan or wish for
or support the same thing sometimes we
actually get mad at people for doing
things that we think are wrong but we
actually support it might even be that
person right we might have not LED them
on in certain respects and so you know
there's that group and then there's the
people who are rightly criticizing us
and saying hey don't you do that sort of
thing and we tend to get angry with
either so he says um
it's not through their fault but through
the law of our own you know uh mortality
that we suffer unpleasantness that comes
from the gods you know so we shouldn't
even be mad at them right now he gives a
lot of examples and I think these
examples are very relatable the first
one that he starts with
speaking ill of you
he says suppose you're told someone has
spoken ill of you
consider this whether you did it first
consider how many you bad mouth I stress
this point let's reflect that some
aren't doing us are wrong but are
actually returning one some are acting
on our behalf under under others under
duress others in ignorance right so
people are saying bad things about us
don't we do that ourselves why are we so
angry at them doing it
another great example lusting for
another's spouse and he notes that those
who do in fact you know lost after and
perhaps pursue flirt with create a
dating profile and and connect up with
other people's Partners it doesn't just
have to be spouses it could be
boyfriends girlfriends whatever you want
right
that they get upset when somebody does
the same thing to them they want to
flirt with everybody else's spouses but
if anybody flirts with their spouse ooh
now they're mad they're being a
hypocrite right they're being
inconsistent and a little bit of
self-awareness could help them to first
of all realize they shouldn't be
flirting with other people's spouses
unless their spouse is you know cool
with that uh but they shouldn't be
getting upset with uh this this other
person for doing the same as them
um another great example and here's
where I think that this fetus could be
translated quite productively as loyalty
right he says the man who makes the
sharpest demands on another's good faith
is faithless himself he wants everybody
else not to let him down to you know be
advising him about everything in timely
manners to follow through on their
agreements but he doesn't do the same to
them this is a big problem by the way
when there's any sort of you know power
imbalance the boss doesn't do what it is
that they demand the employees to do you
know we're all one big happy family sure
uh Happy Family where daddy or Mommy
rules the roost and everybody else is
supposed to show them loyalty but they
don't show loyalty or good faith to
anybody else well that's that's a real
problem there lying to others right we
don't like when people lie he says the
man who chases down lies is himself a
perjurer and you're telling lies himself
a lot of people get get upset about
things that they are doing and it's a
way of projecting it onto others
bringing false charges here he has in
mind the law court right because he
talks about being sued a person who
brings all sorts of false charges abuses
the legal institutions gets mad when
somebody else does that to them oh this
isn't fair I can't believe that they're
using the very the same mechanism of
Justice against me that I used against
others he also talks about being angry
with people who punish slaves and then
going home and punishing your own slaves
there's a lot of this and it doesn't
have to be slaves it could be tracking
about other people's families and their
Dynamics it could be talking about other
people's workplaces it could be any sort
of group situation where again there's a
power imbalance and one person gets to
punish another he talks about indulging
appetites and here he gets a little bit
more
specific right he says a father reproves
his son's elaborate Banquets though he's
worse than his son the man who's denied
nothing to his own appetite for luxury
forgives nothing in another man's so you
know indulging in food indulging in
drink other sensual appetites people
condemn each other for doing the same
thing that they either do or wish to do
or did do back in their own time
there's one other one that he brings up
and this is in chapter uh
uh here we go chapter 35 of book three
he returns to this topic and I think
this is a really important one
you're indignant that a slave answered
back to you and a Freeman too and your
wife and a client then you turn around
and complain that the Free Speech you've
destroyed at home has been torn from the
Commonwealth right so you're saying oh
everybody's restricting My Free Speech
uh it's cancel culture pick whatever
other trendy term you want
but you won't let other people say
things
you want everybody to shut up and listen
to you
and at the same time you're not
extending that same frankness or freedom
of speech which was you know considered
very important in ancient times to the
people that are close to you not just
subordinates but even your friends and
your family you're shutting them up and
demanding that they don't say their
piece and yet you want to say yours all
of these are you know instances where
somebody is showing a lack of
self-awareness or they're just a jerk
and they think that everybody else
should be bound by rules that don't
apply to them that they're an exception
right so Seneca thinks that if we're
attentive to this and we not only you
know look at these sort of instances
where it's likely to happen but we keep
in mind how we get there the assumptions
that go into this partiality you could
say on our own Parts excusing ourself
for Behavior but wanting to hold other
people accountable for it and interpret
for their actions in bad ways and
interpret our actions or even Desires in
good ways if we can start to undo that
we will be less angry people so this is
a very important section within seneca's
on anger giving us a concrete set of
ways modes of analyzing our own behavior
and not just Behavior but planning
desires and what it is that we support
so that we will be a little less
hypocritical and therefore less angry